il se rappelle des souvenirs anciens oui
mais formidable parce que on avait joué
ensemble un machine à écrire de coke
toile à la salle luxembourg à ce moment
là puisqu'on avait les deux salles et ça
a été son départ foudroyant je veux dire
parce que elle avait été de fantastiques
dans mail avait joué aussi au français
l'avait joué mademoiselle de jacques de
bâle l avenue moins longtemps ou deux
ans oui je regrette d'ailleurs c'est
dommage mais enfin c'est une fille
tellement équilibré et tellement elle
sait très bien ce qu'est ce qu'elle
devait faire
elle est parti en douceur d'ailleurs
comme jean-louis ben oui comme comme
mort aux sig était passé aux français
mais je sais par la dû se rendre compte
que pour elle et qu'elle se considérait
plus comme une actrice moderne que comme
une actrice classique spectateur j'ai
donc l'élève de madame marguerite
institutrice 7e c'est à dire je prépare
mes élèves à l'entrée en sixième mais
vos élèves sont les spectateurs voilà
vous savez la performance pour vos
retours
oui je sais pas j'aime pas beaucoup
pensé à ça parce que je sais que je me
suis lavé lima proposait justement aps
il m'a dit au téléphone c'est un
monologue alors violemment à la jambe
était tout le monde non je ne parle
justement ça et finalement ce n'est pas
un monologue du tout c'est un dialogue
c'est à dire que que vous voyez par
exemple en ce moment je le répète mais
je répète avec des ddd fauteuil qui ont
des deus comme sa leçon sa sinistre puis
très envie d'avoir quelqu'un devant moi
j'ai envie de lui parler
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est que
notre squelette reconnaissable à ses
eaux un jour chacun de vous sera
exactement comme ça on pourra pas lui
serrer la main parce qu'il sera enterré
je me suis par exemple ne s'est jamais
vu comme ça tue sa femme ou ses amis
rentrent et tout à coup il ne s'écrirait
pas en danger parce qu'ils ne
reconnaîtraient pas venu à ce moment-là
plus tu rapproche les squelettes vers le
plus possible dans les publics parlent
pas ce permis
comme ça oui alors tu les laisses ta
circulent mais valence et valence est
tout seul
huit ans après pour votre retour vers
l'asie la facilité je ne sais pas au
fond tu essaies tu que c'est très
difficile
finalement c'est pas une pièce de
théâtre clémence est un dialogue
vivement avec des personnes je trouve ça
assez fabuleux je veux dire de pouvoir
même si c'est dans le truchement du
d'une pièce enfin évidemment sans les
idées de l'auteur mais je trouve qu'il
ya des idées comme ça c'est assez belle
et il y en a certains qui certaines qui
m'amuse d'autres il semble complètement
vieillotte ou erronées mais il y en a
une actualité fabuleuse et puis aussi il
y a une une sincérité il y a une bonne
amie il ya une bonne santé finalement
dans cette pièce est ce que j'aime
justement c'est de pouvoir parler à des
gens alors posez vos crayons et répondez
à la question de madame marguerite
quel est à votre avis la partie la plus
importante la tête
ah bon pourquoi la tête est ce que
voudrait la tête posée sur deux villes
le tronc les membres est bien la vérité
c'est que vous êtes tombé dans le
panneau ni la tête ni le temps ni les
bras dirigeants n'ont aucune importance
et je sais que tout ça
ici ça la merde
est ce que vous croyez que my way va
vous faire l'éloge du corps humain et du
plaisir qu'on peut en tirer le break
n'est pas à une épicurienne
c'est quoi une épicurienne et c'est une
femme qui suit le régime des piqûres qui
sont cons epicure c'était un grec qui ne
pensaient qu'au plaisir